with Islamic state we know that they
were killing people who had been taken
hostage we know that they were killing
people who would have committed some
sort of minor crimes and were then left
in their bodies left in the square
outside we know that they had invaded
Mosul we know that they had effectively
taken away what was an original
revolution against a bashar al-assad and
yet you stayed with it but now you're
sort of saying that there's a link here
between the coalition but Islamic state
was attacking and killing
indiscriminately now that must have been
clear to you say that their coalition
attacked because they thought that their
interests were threat know and maybe
they felt that the barbaric behavior
Islamic state was such that they had to
intervene if we say that they're
attacked because their interest is their
interests was at stake this is something
comprehendible what's not comprehendible
is to say that they were they decided to
carry out their campaign in defense of
human rights atrocities or what is
considered human rights atrocities the
judicial system or the stoning of the
adulterer cut in the hand of the thief
and all the treatment of luck
homosexuals and if this was the case and
this is a point that we had discussed
with some the DoD in the interrogations
then I'm sure America would have taken a
clear stance against Saudi Arabia who is
well known for their application of some
of the penal systems or the penal codes
of his of Islam or from the religious
texts such as stoning such as the
beheadings and of like a sorcerer's or
and so on but America doesn't not just
take us not unuq that matter they don't
just not take a stance they even host
them the Queen hosts the king of Saudi
Arabia they sit with them they actually
joined a coalition with them so if that
was the case but yeah I get that point
but people do make complaints about that
in the UK the point of the matter is if
you were against the bloody Islamic
state we're doing you weren't going to
be able to complain you couldn't start
and stop it you chose not to
therefore you are complicit in whatever
was going
no that is a unacceptable notion that
because somebody didn't speak out that
they were complicit complacent or
complicit complicit because not every
person who didn't say no to the Iraq war
or the invasion of Afghanistan or the
trustees in Abu Ghraib or we say that
they're complicit as well the question I
suppose is though that you did join up
you did go you're in racket you're
seeing these things that are taking
place are you saying that you simply
couldn't do anything with it
the point here is that to simply say
that because a person is not proven they
said or did anything in objection to an
act that a governance that they will
live in under committed to say that
they're complicit this is not this is it
just seems to stretch the realms of
logical thinking and your logical
argument is I understand the point of
the argument is you're not actually
compelled to stay in a cut in a state
that has set itself up and is murdering
indiscriminately and being bobbled by
God but by compelled by any standards
the religious standards it must be an
Islamic what they'll be heading and
killing the throwing of homosexuals off
the building leaving bodies out we're
ready saying this time their religious
obligation or fallen under the Imam or
the caliph stretches beyond your
agreement of his policies or his
understanding or his methodology in
jurisprudence in Islamic law I can
differ with the Imam in how we
understand Islamic law but as long as he
is the Imam just like conservative and
labor do all the labor people just start
breaking the law when they're well knows
that that's the point you see this is
actually making links to governments
that don't just unilaterally start
carrying out remarkable acts of violence
and invading sovereign countries which
they have not no that's exactly what
they do
when I I don't think that America came
here and with the approval of the Syrian
government even though the Syrian
government is considered by
international law sovereign government
I don't think they SAP 20 basis on on
the soil Assyrian soil with their proof
of the Syrian government this is exactly
where it is you must have been aware of
course of the videos that were being
produced of life there and obviously the
videos of people being murdered now what
did you think about that this propaganda
but it's been more than propaganda isn't
it
mmm no it literally is propaganda us
exactly what media is it's meant to tell
a narrative and that was the narrative
that and I guess the decision-makers saw
that they wanted to put out and what did
you think about their narrative or that
and the narrative and the fact that it
people were being killed I have my own
personal views about it probably not
something I wish to share on on the
media I mean did you not think to
yourselves well this isn't what I signed
up for what isn't
the fact that people are just being
murdered and it's being put out on on
video that has really quite horrendous I
mean most people accept their horror
movies just the point of like this isn't
what I signed up for it's a bit like a
said if coalition airstrike carried out
like a carry down one of these
airstrikes and under the collateral
damage or the guise of collateral damage
we don't say oh is this what you signed
up for but I didn't sign up for anything
of course and that's the point I made it
so you did sign up and became members of
Islamic state I'm not a member of any
armed forces of at all so there is a
difference they could click distinction
between being a Alliant religiously to
the Islamic state and being part of
fighting force of the Islamic state or a
green with Islamic state policy
everything is separate you cannot bunch
them all into one category or British
isn't right
do you agree of everything the British
government does
outside of the UK I think if I saw
bodies in in the middle of a square in
the centre of what is effectively my
capital city I would have a really big
issue with it but you apparently didn't
maybe because your your United Kingdom
is not Syria like I said this was
something that was being carried out by
so-called allies of America and UK and
other countries Russia and other
superpowers of the world Yvon told me
specifically their bodies being put into
the central square in Raqqa which it
there and being left on Rails right now
you did you have to have seen it
justifying anything Islamic state did
it's not it's not an obligation or duty
of me to justify or condemn anything and
but the point we're trying to make is
that you being a British sis and you
don't turn around one day when Britain
commits some war crime or some kind of
act of terrorism and say this isn't what
I signed up for because you didn't sign
up for it you were born broish right
many people like myself who became
religiously aligned to the Islamic state
it's a default just like being born into
a certain country it's a default I'm
almost like you did sign up and my
question is surely when you can see
these things these atrocities you can
see bodies on the streets you know
people are being arrested and and and an
executed confusing the issue of course
no she's not I'm saying there's no
conscription it's by default you've your
Muslim is to you happy I don't think
every Muslim in the world joins demyx
day this is this is according to their
understanding of Islam no this is just
surely a straight moral question as
anyone could see blowing up kids in a in
a general sense I think we've made it
clear I mean if you want to talk about
specifics I would prefer Moulton engage
in specific condemnation not considering
my current disposition don't know do you
think that there will be more attacks to
come I think based on that type of
mentality that type of thinking there
will be lots of things that will happen
on both sides of the spectrum
many more people like myself will be
stripped of Rights or citizenships
because of this narrow thinking many
more innocent people may be harmed
because of this narrow understanding of
holding people accountable for things
that they didn't do so yeah this this
type of narrow mindedness will only
breed more negativity and violence and
and it's on both sides